えーと ご質問がございましたらどうぞ
お尋ねしますけれど 行禅を 2年半ほど 30分ぐらいやっていまして
で その後 最近 1年ぐらい 1時間ぐらい毎日やってるんですが
最近やってる最中 それから終わった後に腰がかなりムキムキ痛くなりまして
そういうのって悪魔なんですね
あの やっぱり肉体のことですから
気にせずやればいいってことなんですか
そうそう 負けたらあかん
自分の根性なんで こうやって試しているのは
だから我が身は可愛いというあれでやられちゃいます
それから これだったら危ない病気やというところもそうですよ
それは そういうことで
とにかくもうやめさせたいということなんです
それも自分の心から生まれるんだから
もう何のことなく消えます
やる それでもやりますよと思っただけで
さっと消えます はい  あと
それがすみません やる時間帯っていうのは特にいつでもいいんでしょうか
それはどんな時間でもいいんですけど
朝 時間が勤めに間に合わないものですから 3
時半前ぐらいから始めてるんですけど
別にそれはどうだろうと
思います 大丈夫です うん
ありがとうございます
ご質問です はい  あの 今日の話とはちょっとずれるんですけれども
最近ですね 昨日も報道にありましたけれども
今ミャンマーの方で軍事政権下でですね
かなりの政情不安になっていて
その中でテレビでしか報道は見ていないんですけれども
仏教の僧侶の皆さんがですね
抗議行動を デモをされているという映像を見たんですけれども
そういった仏教のですね
テーラワーダの仏教から見てですね
その僧侶の皆さんの行動というのはどのように捉えられているんでしょうか
そして その今のミャンマーの政情不安というのは
これからどのような方向に行くというふうに考えられているのでしょうか
仏教はこの 少宗派で個人の有志たちの集まりでやっていた時代では
いわゆる初期仏教 お釈迦様の時代ではね
構わない 構わない 構うなよ
俗世間のことを離れなさいよ
語ることさえもやめなさいと言って禁止してあるんです
それで仏教の仲間が出てくると
仲間のことは徹底的に心配しなさい
しなさいよと 誰かが病気になったら
すぐできるだけのことをしなさいよと
誰かが修行がもうちょっとうまくいかなかったら
勝手に出て行ってでもアドバイスして助けてあげなさいよというふうなことになるんですよ
仏教の仲間の中で そこで仏教徒っていうのは出家
在家同じだから 一緒に上下はあるんだけど
みんな同じ兄弟という感じでいるんです
そうなってくると もう仲間が苦しんでると放っておいてはならないんですね
放っておけないではなくて
それで歴史的にどうなるのかというと
仏教が広がると もう家族がちょっと大きすぎなんですね
そこで国全体になってくると
家族が国全体家族になっちゃうんですね
そうなってくると その中に政治があるんです
歴史的にそういう風になってしまっちゃうんです
だから 今我々日本にいるような感じで
政府の外にいるでしょ
今我々は そんな楽な状況じゃなくなっちゃうんです
まあ例えばスリランカ一番古いんだから
の中でもスリランカに仏教入って
すぐたちまちもう全国仏教徒になってしまう
そうすると王様は仏教徒になっているんだから
もう家族であって みんな仏教徒であって
そんなみんなそれぞれ自分の仕事を通して政治やったりする
宅建をやったりもするということになるんです
そうすると 何か悪いことをしちゃうと
放っておけないではなくて
放っておいてはいけないということになるんです
あんた何やってるの？これは違うでしょうと
ということになる それでも政治は政治だから
もう関係ないことにしなくちゃいけないんですよ
そういうディレンマがあって
もう我慢できるところまで
ギリギリまで出家は我慢する
我慢して もうこれ以上は待てないということになると
もうやっぱり活動はする
それはもう歴史的にも
そんな今 現代そうなるんですけど
昔はそんな派手に恐ろしいことは何ともないんですよ
別に反対すれば終わりですから
王様は 王様のこれがやり方はダメですよと言うと
もうやめるしかもうどうにもならない
で それでまあ私もこの軍事の問題にもその例を出そうと思ったんです
だから出家だから もう在家の人々はもう出家したり還俗したり
お寺で宗教活動をすればいいんじゃないかと
軍事政権何やっても関係ないんじゃないかと
我々は瞑想すればいいんじゃないかということもあり得ますけど
では人間どう苦しんだってもいいのかと
ということは出てくる
ではやっぱり民主運動をやらなくちゃといっても
それがいいかというと
それは道路に出てデモをやったりして
このお坊さんたち何やってるのかということも出てくる
じゃあお寺に閉じこもって何やってるのかと
だから まあ俗世間ではどちらでやったっていても
完璧な正しいということになりません
なりません しかし 決してこの国民のために
苦しんでいる人々のために立ち上がるべき時
立ち上がるということは
仏教はやります それでもかなり変わります
変わらなきゃダメなんです
お坊さんはそれで政治家になろうと思ってないんだから
国がまた平和になったら
またお寺に戻って また瞑想始まるんです
だから 自分に一さじご飯をくれる人々
殺されたり 殴られたり
自由を奪われたり 言論の自由を押し付けたり
抑えられたり それから最低バスにも乗れなくなると
もう運賃が勝手にあげたりとか
これは出家は黙っているわけにはいきませんよ
だから これがやっぱりテーラワーダ世界ではあるんです
すごく管理するんです
政治はちゃんとやっているのかと
でもあれ 完璧にやらないこと知ってますよ
ミャンマーにしてもそこまでいたんだからね
やることっていうのは
私はすごく怒っていたのは
このかなり前  15年ぐらい前から
このお坊さんたち何やってるの？なんであんた方は出家なのに
ブッダの道を歩んでいる人々なのに
自分たちの兄弟のことを心配しないのかと
ある日 こちらに来たあるミャンマーのお坊さんが
なんか自分の瞑想道場にも日本人が来たければどうぞ行ってくださいと
私にはもう政府がね ビザのね
許可を出せるように 自分の道場も認定してくれたと自慢気に言うんです
私はそれだけで気持ち悪くなっちゃって
あなたの道場には誰一人も送りませんと決めたんです
勝手に日本の方々が行くのは自由ですけど
私に聞いたらあの道場に行ってくださいと言わない
何をこれ 軍事政権に認められたっていうことが
道場のすごいことにならんでしょう
ですから やっぱりこれは
もう避けられないんですよ
もうカサブですから カサブの中で起こる政治なんですね
そこはいつも相対的で
仏教徒が地位が低くなると綺麗に政治活動から離れちゃうんです
政治やっている人々が仏教になってくると
あなたが大統領やら総理やということは関係ないんだ
ただ仏教徒でしょうということになるんです
そこはもうその国々ではそういう関係になってます
人を殴ったり殺したりするのは決していいことじゃないしね
まあどうにもならんですけど
とにかく個人の主観 私の主観なんですけど
やっぱりミャンマー人というのは本当にいい人間なんですよ
ものすごい忍耐があって
我慢強くて もうすごく謙虚で
なんであんな人間がね
まあまた国にも貧乏じゃないです
結構ありますよ もう資源とか何でもかんでも
しかしもう貧困のどん底
もうだからかわいそうなんです
というかね 見ていられないってことは自分の個人的な感想でもあります
だからなんとか平和と民主主義という 2つがね
まあ戻ってほしいという希望をするしかないんです
政治家誰かいいということは
仏教徒としては言いませんよ
出家としてはあの人は嫌
この人はこれはもう仏教でもろくなものはないんですけど
だからしかし この軍事政権だけはちょっと現代ではね
昔は王様ですから これは軍曹だからね
まあいいんだけどね でも国民は我が子のように心配してたでしょ
今はそうじゃないでしょ
自分たちだけ もうアメリカ人の武士さんみたいな金持ちになっちゃったけど
一般国民にはもう食べるものもない
ということでね なんとか早く収めてほしいということだけはあります
はい  ではもう一人 もう一方が
じゃあじゃあ  暴走の三宝に帰依し
戒を守り 義の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得た功徳を
神々 先祖 祖母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に満たせますように
そして照らされますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィワジャンツー サッバローゴー ヴィナッサトー マーテー バワットアンテラーヨー スキー
ヴィーガー ユコー バワー バワトゥ サッバ マングラント サッパンツー サッバ デーヴァター サッバ ブッダ
ヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワント テアビワ
ダナシー リッソー ニッチャンワッダ パチャイノー チャッタル ダンマー ヴァッダムティー アジュ ワッノー スカン バラン
サーリプッタ サーリプッタ
もう 3時間も 本当にどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます